do you clean up thank you this is a
fresh look thank you thank you is this a
a new and improved Kane Brown in 2023.
my stylist do they think wow and look at
the hairdo you are on point Mister look
even my producer's like yeah Kane Brown
got it going on so you do have it going
on five nominations tonight how does it
feel to be sitting in Entertainer of the
Year male artists of the Year categories
for the first time ever no no no I mean
it feels awesome you know I'm grateful
to be alive I'm grateful to be here so
honestly it's just the coolest feeling
to feel recognized yeah
God for Miss
wherever she went
I know the first time y'all are
collabing I'm trying to get the
interview with the two of y'all too stay
on the carpet y'all scored three
nominations for this song yeah what a
blessing I'm excited I couldn't have a
better collaborator to work with so um
you know it's awesome I hope we both get
to go up there at least once
[Music]
but I'm performing so it'll be that's
all that's what I'm looking forward to
right now
oh we're working on we're putting out a
studio in the house right now so we're
gonna put the babies to bed and just
work on some music I love it it sounds
like maybe I'll be putting together a
Duets album like a Tim and face it ain't
nothing that we're going to say no to
all right fair enough fair enough uh
Caitlyn recently posted really
good girls just like
just laying on himself on stuff at the
house are we thinking maybe I'll have
some future musicians in the world I
don't know what kingsley's gonna be
she's uh she's a little princess uh
Cody's my brute you know she's 99
everything height weight I hope I'm
hoping she's my my athlete yeah take it
out to Papa yeah
[Music]